Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
J’ai une bonne nouvelle :
j’ai retrouvé mes oreilles !
Eh oui, je les avais perdues !
Il y a longtemps déjà,
parce que jusqu’à récemment,
il faut bien le reconnaître,
j’étais obsédé par l’image, la vision.
Je ne faisais que voir, mirer,
regarder, zieuter, looker,
alors qu’autrefois j’écoutais, j’étais
même un peu spécialisé dans l’écoute :
choriste adolescent, passionné de musique
électro-acoustique à 20 ans,
accro à la radio - je le suis encore -
puis j’ai été emporté par le maelström
des images, celle des réseaux sociaux,
des médias mainstream,
des magazines, des publicités.
Voilà comment j’en suis arrivé
à ne plus écouter.
Heureusement, j'ai retrouvé mes oreilles.
Quel bonheur !
Je vais vous expliquer comment
ça s’est passé - en deux temps.
D’abord, je me souviens,
c’était au printemps 2019 à Arles.
J’étais en formation
dans un workshop de Phonurgia Nova,
une association qui soutient
la création sonore.
Et là, dès le premier jour,
j’ai été content parce que j’ai pu
pratiquer l’exercice du tandem.
On choisit un partenaire, un endroit
tranquille - un parc, une rue.
L’un des deux enroule
autour de ses yeux un foulard -
donc il se masque les yeux.
On l'appellera l'aveugle.
L’autre le prend par la main
et le promène.
On l'appellera le voyant.
Il peut emmener l’aveugle où il veut,
à une condition, bien sûr,
c’est de veiller à sa sécurité.
C'est normal.
Mais l’aveugle, lui,
comme il ne voit rien par définition,
puisqu’il a les yeux bandés,
il se concentre sur ses oreilles.
Et c’est ainsi que, jouant le rôle
de l’aveugle à mon tour,
je me suis concentré sur mes oreilles
et j’ai progressivement
retrouvé le sens de l’ouïe.
Ça, c’est absolument extraordinaire.
Le deuxième événement,
c’était un an plus tard, le premier
confinement - donc printemps 2020.
Et là, génial !
Plus d’avions dans le ciel,
pas de voitures sur les routes,
pas de tracteurs dans les champs.
Mes oreilles se sont retrouvées
comme deux belles plantes épanouies
qui poussent dans la forêt.
Chaque jour, je faisais ma petite balade.
J’avais droit à un kilomètre, et puis
elles croissaient, elles croissaient.
C'était devenu des feuilles de choux.
Ça se passait dans la forêt
de Fontevraud l'Abbaye.
J’étais vraiment complètement
pris par cette forêt.
C'était absolument extraordinaire.
Nous avons appelé cela
la « forêt déconfinée ».
La forêt déconfinée parce que
le confinement des uns, les humains,
peut être le déconfinement des autres,
les animaux, les végétaux.
J’ai dit « nous » parce que
je n’étais pas seul.
J’étais avec ma compagne Madlen
Herrström, l’artiste plasticienne,
qui, pendant que j’enregistre
les sons, les dessine.
Nous appelons cela « relever
les empreintes sonores des territoires ».
Et mon fils, artiste
lui aussi, et designer,
a pris les dessins
et les a mis en mouvement.
Eh bien, je vous invite
à découvrir un court extrait
de cette création « La forêt déconfinée ».
C’est une création vidéo.
On regarde un petit extrait,
ça va vous mettre dans l’ambiance.
C’est le groupe Soundmark -
empreinte sonore en anglais.
(Vidéo)
(Vent qui souffle)
Parce que j’ai vécu cette expérience,
je vais pouvoir vous expliquer comment,
en retenant notre respiration,
en écoutant la nature,
en faisant silence, nous laissons entrer
en nous un concentré du monde
et communions
avec l’ensemble de ses hôtes.
Mais pour réussir cette expérience
sensorielle de communion avec le vivant,
il faut trouver le point d’équilibre
entre notre conscience intérieure
et notre conscience du monde extérieur.
Ce point d'équilibre, on peut l'atteindre
grâce à un apprentissage.
L’écoute est une affaire
de volonté individuelle.
Mais ça dépend aussi de la société.
Or, nous vivons dans une société
du bruit généralisé.
Les automobiles dans les villes,
les tracteurs dans les campagnes,
les avions dans le ciel et même
les médias bruissent de mille bruits.
Rien d’étonnant dans ces conditions qu’on
constate dans nos sociétés aujourd’hui
une régression de l’écoute.
Au-delà de la perte auditive entraînée
par des environnements bruyants,
nous avons subi ce qu’on appelle
de nouvelles surdités.
Par exemple, nous nous sommes mis
à porter des écouteurs
dans la rue, dans les transports.
Ce qui nous a refermés
finalement sur nous-mêmes.
Et puis il y a un monde autour
de nous qui est apparu.
Le monde selon Bip.
Montres, téléphones portables,
ordinateurs, automobiles, jeux vidéo,
plein de gadgets émettent
des signaux électroniques aigus
qui frappent vos oreilles,
là où, jusqu’à présent, seuls les
sons de certains petits animaux
les sollicitaient.
Résultat : nos oreilles sont saturées.
Notre écoute a battu en retraite.
Alors, ma question, c’est : que reste-t-il
de notre capacité d’écoute originelle ?
Est-ce qu’il est encore possible
d’écouter dans ce monde ?
Tout n’est pas perdu.
Il y a des solutions.
Nous devons agir, chacun de nous.
Les politiques d’abord, à l’échelle
locale, ville, quartier, village.
Vous me direz, les politiques en matière
d’écoute ne sont pas les mieux placés.
Vous n’avez pas tout à fait tort,
mais l’immense majorité d’entre eux
sont des élus locaux et territoriaux.
Or, l’écoute a toujours fait territoire
et les sons sont
des marqueurs territoriaux.
Vous pouvez reconnaître le village
où vous êtes né, la cloche de l’église,
le quartier où vous avez grandi,
cette fontaine, là,
au croisement de deux ruelles,
on appelle ça des sons totémiques.
Et quand je dis
que l’écoute fait territoire :
de tout temps,
les chasseurs dans les forêts
ont appris à se déplacer furtivement,
sans faire de bruit,
de façon à ne pas être repérés
et à entendre leur proie approcher.
Il y a même le pic épeiche qui, l'hiver
venu, quand la végétation a disparu,
frappe de son bec une branche.
Il délimite ainsi son territoire.
Les chercheurs en écologie ont observé
que les oiseaux qui utilisent
les sons pour communiquer
se regroupent en soundtope.
Ce sont tout simplement des zones
où il y a un maximum d’interactions
acoustiques entre les espèces.
Eh bien, Bernie Krause,
l’audio-naturaliste américain
a observé exactement la même chose.
Il a montré que, au lever du jour, les
espèces se partagent des plages horaires,
certaines avançant ou
au contraire retardant leur chant
pour ne pas être concurrencées
par une autre espèce.
Une étude britannique a montré que dans
les villes, il se passe exactement cela.
Les oiseaux se décalent pour
reconstruire leur niche acoustique.
Les humains, eux, ne se décalent pas trop.
Ils ont tendance à monter
le volume des sons
et à renchérir les uns sur les autres.
C’est la raison pour laquelle
nous devons, nous aussi, humains,
apprendre à partager la bande passante
acoustique avec les autres qu’humains
et avec les humains aussi.
La question de l’écoute
est au cœur de nos sociétés.
L’audio-diversité
est en voie d’extinction.
Il y a une femme extrêmement
importante dans cette histoire,
c’est l’Américaine, biologiste,
Rachel Carson.
Rachel Carson a lancé
un cri d’alarme en 1962
dans son livre
« Le printemps silencieux ».
Avec la disparition accélérée
de la biodiversité dans le monde,
un grand nombre de sons avaient disparu
sans que nous ayons pris le soin
de les enregistrer.
Eh bien, depuis cette époque,
l’accélération de ce mouvement
de perte de disparition de la biodiversité
fait que c'est bien pire.
Un chiffre : 75% des insectes volants
ces 30 dernières années
ont disparu
dans nos campagnes occidentales.
Alors l’audio-diversité,
si on veut la conserver,
il est temps de s’occuper de protéger
notre patrimoine sonore,
territoire par territoire.
Et il y a un petit bout de territoire
en France, un petit bout de littoral,
dont je voudrais vous parler.
C’est là où cette année a été créée
la première réserve de vagues,
à Saint-Pierre-Quiberon.
On va regarder une deuxième création
du groupe Soundmark.
(Vidéo) (Bruit de vagues)
Reconquérir notre écoute
doit être notre combat.
Les politiques ne suffiront pas.
Nous devons agir, chacun de nous,
individus, familles, associations.
Comment ?
Aidez-vous de l’exercice suivant.
Vous êtes en ville ou dans la nature.
Choisissez un point d'écoute central.
Asseyez-vous.
Dessinez, sur une feuille
de papier, un cercle.
Et reportez-y, dans ce cercle,
tous les sons qui vous parviennent
en précisant leur nature, leur origine,
leurs caractéristiques.
Ainsi, vous allez faire travailler
vos oreilles et réapprendre à écouter.
Plus globalement, plus généralement,
en vous concentrant
sur les sons autour de vous,
vous pouvez progresser
considérablement en écoute.
Pour cela, il y a une façon
de faire qui est très simple :
vous cultivez votre écoute
en la développant, en l’intensifiant.
C'est une démarche gagnante.
Vous n'avez rien à perdre.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que la qualité de l’écoute
engendre des dynamiques
relationnelles positives
qui bénéficient aussi bien à l’individu
qu’à la communauté.
Écouter stimule la curiosité,
la sensibilité,
l’imagination, l’empathie.
Ça développe même un climat
de coopération et d’entraide.
Vous le voyez,
l’écoute a d’immenses bienfaits.
Elle est participation.
En écoutant, on interagit avec les autres
espèces, on engage tous nos sens.
Elle est création même.
Elle est composition.
Quand vous vous déplacez dans une rue
en vous concentrant sur les sons,
votre oreille se déplace.
Elle zoome sur un son.
Elle navigue d'un plan à un autre.
Elle compose.
Pour illustrer
cette notion d’écoute création,
je vous invite à découvrir
maintenant une dernière création
dans laquelle nous a rejoints
ma fille Selma, artiste textile,
qui a conçu et réalisé les supports
sur lesquels nous projetons nos vidéos,
comme au mois de mai
dans le blockhaus de l’Île de Nantes,
que vous allez maintenant découvrir.
(Vidéo)(Musique)(Divers sons)
Pour conclure, ensemble, écoutons.
Écoutons les sons.
Écoutons le grand orchestre du vivant.
Relions-nous au monde.
Écoutons la terre,
le ciel, l’eau.
Écoutons les humains et les autres
qu’humains, animaux, végétaux,
minéraux.
Écoutons parler nos rivières,
nos forêts,
nos océans, nos montagnes.
Écoutons la ville aussi.
Grimpons sur les collines, les coteaux,
les hauteurs.
Captons le chant de nos cités,
de nos contrées.
Écoutons les battements
de notre cœur.
Écoutons les silences.
Je vous remercie de votre écoute.
(Applaudissements)